I have this outfit that I wear it's
almost like a uniform I put about 16
months into testing probably in total
four to five hundred different pieces of
clothing this beater I tried 30 or 40
different types of beaters to get the
right brand and then when I had the
right brand for material and stretch and
cut standpoint then I tried different
sizes from my shoes perspective I can go
to the pool I can go to the restaurant I
can lift in these I can walk in these
without getting blisters they don't
smell bad you're like well you probably
can't get into restaurants with a beater
and you're right which is why I have
finals that I put on top and these are
nice and stretchy I have four different
temperature settings I can button this
all the way down button both of these
button this up all the way I can have it
down and open I can have it open and I
can roll my sleeves up and so it just
gives me the most flexibility which is
why I call it my Darwin outfit because
I'm the most adaptable